ja ausgehend von der eigenen situation
wird natürlich immer wieder der eigene
schicksalsschlag wachgerufen
aber es wächst auch das unverständnis
über die gefahren im straßenverkehr und
bergen und jedes mal wieder darüber dass
aus diesen schlimmen ereignissen einfach
nicht gelernt wird
ja wenn ich dass die tage meiner frau
nenne meine frau die das beurteilt
wir haben aber lebenslänglich bekommen
er sagt eigentlich sehr viel denn für
die beiden jungs war das thema damit
abgehakt zumal wenn man sieht wie sie
grinsend aus dem gerichtssaal heraus
gegangen sind dann war das nochmal ein
zweiter schlag für uns damit haben wir
immer noch zu knabbern
ja die opfer die angehörigen von opfern
sind häufig ein zweites mal bestraft
worden
durch die art und weise wie vorher die
sache letztendlich begutachtet worden
ist und ich bin sehr froh dass
inzwischen die erkenntnis gewachsen ist
dass man eher nicht von
ordnungswidrigkeiten spricht sondern
inzwischen von straftaten und
dementsprechend auch das anders
behandelt werden
dass ein solches eine solche tat einen
billigen des in kauf nehmen und damit
auch eine töte und damit auch letztlich
vielleicht ein mord beinhaltet das habe
ich immer schon als meinung zu vertreten